-It's becoming clear
that President Trump
has no way out
of the government shutdown
he's boxed himself into.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Suspenseful theme plays ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
The shutdown is having real
effects for millions of people
and that includes
law enforcement officials
going without pay.
Yesterday, in his
confirmation hearing,
Trump's pick for attorney
general, William Barr,
was asked about the effect
on law enforcement
and said the shutdown was
the fault of both sides.
- People would like to see
the shutdown ended
and that's why people wanna see
some kind of compromise
and, you know, you call it
the Trump shutdown,
but, I mean,
it takes two to tango.
-Okay, but this is not a tango.
Trump is the only one dancing.
[ Laughter ]
And, judging from how
he moves his hands, he's doing
some off-brand version
of the Macarena.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, look at 'im. He looks
like a grandpa at a wedding.
[ Laughter ]
♪ Hey, macaroni ♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's not both sides.
We all remember the meeting
in the Oval Office
where Trump literally said
he was proud
to shut down the government
and, yet,
despite the fact
that he is on camera,
saying the shutdown
would be his fault,
Trump actually thinks he's
winning the argument.
CNN reported yesterday
that Trump has been
telling aides and allies
that he believes
he is winning the battle
for public support.
Well, of course
he believes that.
He watches more Fox News
than all the residents
of a Texas senior center,
combined.
[ Laughter and light clapping ]
Trump always thinks he
can win any fight.
He can be in the Octagon
with Conor McGregor,
takin' a kick to the face,
and he'd say, "Did you see?
I just head-butted his foot
with my face."
[ Laughter and light clapping ]
Trump also thinks
his Oval Office speech
on the wall last week
really moved public opinion
to his side.
Now, you might be asking
yourself, "Wait,
Trump gave a speech from the
Oval Office last week?"
And that's because everyone
has already forgotten about it.
[ Laughter ]
That speech was only a week ago
and it's already been eclipsed
by several insane news stories,
from Trump's trip
to the southern border
to the fact that the FBI thought
he was a Russian asset,
to the fact that
the White House
is serving so much fast food,
they've added a drive-thru.
[ Laughter and applause ]
What's next, is he gonna --
[ Applause ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
Is he gonna try to achieve
peace in the Middle East
with a summit
at Chuck E. Cheese?
[ Laughter ]
[as Trump] No quarters for
anyone 'til you sort this out.
[ Laughter ]
So, yes, Trump really did
give a primetime address
on the wall last week
and he thinks it helped sway
public opinion to his side,
but the actually polling
says something very different.
-Within the last half hour,
Quinnipiac has come out
with a new poll, asking,
"Did the president's speech
last week from the Oval Office
[ Laughter ]
change your mind
about the wall?"
Only 2% said yes.
-2%?!
Maybe the speech
only polled at 2%
because Trump's eye
was only 2% open.
That's why he thinks
he can win any fight.
He's Popeye, except, with bacon,
instead of spinach.
[ Laughter ]
Trump's argument is not working
'cause it's detached
from reality.
It's also very hard to follow.
For example, Trump has recently
found a new favorite line
that he keeps repeating at all
of his public appearances:
"Walls work
because cars have wheels."
-They say a wall is medieval.
Well, so is a wheel.
A wheel is older than a wall.
[ Laughter ]
And I looked and every
single car out there,
even the really expenses ones,
[ Laughter ]
that the Secret Service uses --
and believe me,
they are expensive.
I said,
"Do they all have wheels?"
"Yes."
Oh, I thought it was medieval.
The wheel is older than
the wall, you know that?
And, uh, there are
some things that work.
You know what?
A wheel works and a wall works.
They say it's medieval.
Well, so is the wheel, medieval.
I looked at all the vans and all
of the serious equipment
that they surrounded me with
yesterday.
-Mm.
-The Secret Service, the police,
the Border Patrol, ICE.
Every one of those
had the wheel.
Well, they say wheels
are medieval, too.
But some things don't change.
Wheels and walls.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, um,
I'm worried about Grandpa.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, no. It's, uh --
[ Applause and cheering ]
Yeah.
[ Whistling ]
[ Applause ]
No, it's a wheel wall.
Yeah, it's a wheel wall.
[ Laughter ]
I gotta go.
He just keeps saying the same
things over and over.
In other words,
he's hitting a wall
and it's his brain is going
around like a wheel.
[ Laughter ]
But I guess, now, we know what
Trump's been doing all day
in the Oval Office
during the shutdown:
Just starin' out the window,
countin' all the wheels
on the car.
[ Laughter ]
One, two, three, four.
One, two,
three, four.
Oh, no, a bus!
This isn't gonna be easy.
[ Laughter ]
Now, as dumb as Trump's argument
is, he was actually going
to get another chance
to make it later this month,
to yet another
primetime audience,
for his annual
State of the Union address.
But presidents technically
have to be invited
to give the State of the Union
by the speaker of the House
and, today,
because of the shutdown,
Speaker Nancy Pelosi
asked Trump to reschedule
his State of the Union address
or deliver it in writing.
[ Laughter ]
That's such a great burn
because, you know,
when Trump heard reschedule,
he thought, [as Trump] "Yes!"
But when he heard deliver it
in writing, he thought,
[as Trump] "No-o-o-o-o!"
[ Laughter ]
I would love to see Trump write
down his State of the Union.
I can imagine what
that would look like.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's fun!
It's fun.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
Fun, picturing Trump sittin'
down at a typewriter,
punchin' the keys one at a time
with his sweaty hand paws.
[ Laughter ]
[as Trump] Is wall spelled
with one L or four?
[ Laughter ]
I'll just use all the L's.
What we're witnessing right now
are the desperate gasps
of the Trump agenda.
The wall was
the signature promise
of his campaign and presidency.
He's been talkin' about it
for three and a half years,
but, now, it's slipping away,
with Democrats
in control of the House,
and, in his desperation
to save face and get a deal,
Trump is throwing everything
he said about the wall
out the window.
For example, he said
Democrats didn't even have
to call it a wall and offered
one very strange suggestion.
-This is where I asked
the Democrats to come back
to Washington and to vote
for money for the wall,
the barrier, whatever you
wanna call it's okay with me.
They can name it whatever.
They can name it Peaches.
[ Laughter ]
I don't care what they name it.
-They should call his bluff
and name it Donald Trump's BO.
[ Laughter ]
Then, his supporters
would have to say,
"Donald Trump's BO
has been very effective
in keeping immigrants
out of the country."
[ Laughter ]
And that isn't even
the weirdest suggestion
for what the wall should be
called because, last week,
Louisiana Republican
Senator John Kennedy said,
"You can call it a barrier.
You can call it a wall.
You can call it a wang doodle,
[ Laughter ]
for all I care.
Wang doodle and peaches don't
sound like names for a wall.
They sound like a euphemism
for a guy's junk.
[ Laughter ]
Did you hear about Rudy?
He accidentally sat
on his wang doodle
and banged it into his peaches
and that explains
why he looks like that.
[ Applause and cheering ]
So, now --
[ Applause ]
Now, Trump is throwing out all
of his campaign promises
about the wall and saying
Democrats can call it
whatever they want,
but one thing he guaranteed,
the one thing that was crucial
to the whole idea
was that it would be
impossible to get through.
-So we're gonna build a wall
and it's gonna be impenetrable.
We will begin working
on an impenetrable, physical,
tall, powerful, beautiful,
southern border wall.
-Physical, powerful,
and beautiful.
Was he building a wall
or setting up a Tinder
profile for it?
[ Laughter ]
[as Trump] Physical, tall,
powerful, beautiful,
works hard, plays harder.
[ Laughter ]
And, as dumb as the wall is,
literally the only point
to building one
is to make it impenetrable
and Trump repeatedly promised
he could do it
because that's what he does.
He's a builder!
-Look, as a builder, nobody
in the history of this country
has ever known so much about
infrastructure as Donald Trump.
I build infrastructure.
Do I know how to build a wall?
Our nation's in such trouble.
That's why being a builder,
and a great builder,
and a very successful builder,
I think, will greatly help.
Donald Trump, another
great builder in New York,
now a politician.
I can't stand this.
A politician!
I don't wanna be called
a politician.
-Oh, don't worry.
No one --
[ Laughter and applause ]
No one thinks
you're a politician.
We think of you as a politician
the way we think of Shaq
as a movie star.
[ Laughter ]
So, the only point
in building a wall is
to make it impenetrable
and, yet, last week,
it was reported that testing
of a prototype proved
it could be cut through
with a saw.
And they even got a photo
of the wall
after it had been sawed open.
Last week, Trump was asked
about that report
and the guy
who repeatedly promised
an impenetrable wall
said this --
-What good is a steel wall
if they can saw through it?
-Well, that's a wall that
was designed
by previous administrations.
There's nothing that can't be
penetrated, but you fix it.
But it's a very difficult
thing to do.
But that's a wall,
and they have other walls.
We have many
walls under consideration.
[ Laughter ]
-I love how you can tell
when Trump is lying,
because he circles
through every explanation
he can think of in five seconds.
[as Trump]
It was Obama's fault.
Nothing is impenetrable.
We have other walls.
[ Laughter ]
Next, he's gonna say,
[as Trump] They can't saw
through the new one
because we made it out of saws.
[ Laughter ]
All right, but so what?
Maybe they can just find a new,
stronger material and make sure
the wall's impenetrable.
Problem solved, right?
I mean, it's not like
there's some other,
superobvious way
to get around a wall.
-During a roundtable discussion
with law enforcement officials,
Mr. Trump was told
some border crossers
had been digging tunnels
under areas where walls
are already in place.
-Here, this is just a couple
miles from here,
from where we're standing.
This is a tunnel.
This is the second tunnel that,
recently, we have located.
This is an area
that we actually have wall.
- That's right.
They already had a wall there
and someone just
tunneled under it.
[ Laughter ]
Trump's wall is so stupid that,
not only can it be beaten
by a saw;
it can be beaten by Bugs Bunny.
[ Laughter ]
In fact, if you listen
to Trump explain
how he thinks migrants sneak
across the southern border,
he might actually be thinking
about Bugs Bunny.
-They get off the road and they
drive out into the desert
and they come on.
They make a left turn.
Usually, it's a left,
not a right.
-I knew I shoulda taken
that left toin at Albuquerque.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Every day, we find out more
about how useless the wall is
and that's why public opinion
is against it.
Every time Trump sees
a new poll about the shutdown,
it's like a kick,
in the wang doodle and...
-Peaches.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]